hey guys welcome back to brand new video
Rebecca I'm Munster on a robe again and
today we're gonna be doing a guide on
arc tempered GU shallot day or who just
dropped recently today so to start as
always we want to go over what changes
from Arc attempt or to the normal Koosh
Allah and honestly there's literally one
thing and that's about it and it's not
even really that bad it's just that
flash pods will not knock him out
anymore so flash pods are completely
irrelevant from this fight making this
just a tad bit harder but honestly the
boss is pretty much a cakewalk
regardless but just in case you still
need some help that's why the guide is
here going off at the report his head
leg and tail are breakable and or sever
bolt and you want to be aiming for the
head unless your ranged you should be
going for the tail to maximize your
damage output according to the
weaknesses chart the weakest things he
is weakest to our thunder poison and
blast so try to Center your weapons
around that this one hunting-horn a guy
and my game head a sleep and in
paralysis thing so that works just fine
but still thunder poison and blasts work
just as well if you're Laura I recommend
using mega max and ancient potions as
always with the normal armor skins and
diamond drugs Adam and seeds demon you
know all that stuff the normal mighty
seeds and everything
Rocksteady mantle and the tempura lament
will also work but I also do recommend
earplugs and windproof is a good skill
as well to help with all the wind
pressure moves and the roars and such
the move said he doesn't really have too
many moves at kushell and never really
had many moves to begin with it was
mostly just in the air shooting air at
you but the first move he has is a where
he shoots up in the air and the tornado
spawns right where he flies up he'll do
a lot of dive bomb attacks from there
you can simply just walk through the
wind with the Rocksteady mantle on but
there's really no reason to since gonna
take a lot of damage from you so you
probably shouldn't even be doing that
anyway now obviously the dog bomb
attacks due to a decent amount of damage
you kind of Superman dive if you're
getting really close and you're nervous
that it's going to smack you or you just
keep running around and he probably
won't hit you at all with those moves
next move is this air cannon shot he has
as well if you're up close you will be
taking some damage but if you're far
away you won't take any damage but the
wind pressure will stun you for a bit so
definitely watch out for that so try to
stay out of his range on that move he
kind of likes the caucus head back and
then shoots so you can obviously tell
when he's going to do that move then he
has a lot more of a powerful shot called
the mega cannon just to differentiate
between the more powerful one and the
investor powerful move the mega cannon
shot is basically very similar to the
previous move except even if you're far
away you will take the
and you'll most likely be dead if you're
very up close or if you're not dead
you're gonna be very close to death
because of how damaging that movies in
general and because he's also are
tempered meaning he has like tons of
damage his moveset is basically the same
and there isn't really much of a change
of this boss other than the fact that
this flight may take a little longer
because the flash pots don't work sadly
like I said there he doesn't have too
many moves and they're mostly just a
bunch of wind moves so obviously wind
pressure and you know wind proof and
earplugs works perfectly for this we had
just tips like I said before ear plugs
wind proof work perfect remember not to
bring any flash pods because they're
basically useless and you can use the
crystals in the crystal room to knock
him out a couple times to get some extra
damage like I said my team ran with a
paralysis and a sleep guy with the
hunting-horn that works - sleeping
sleeping him so that you can proc that a
little buff so you can pop down the
barrels do some blast damage on him or
paralyze him with a para toad and the
one portion of the map that also works
as well whatever your team wants to do
or if you want it like I said if you
want to do the solo of course whatever
you want to do but personally to me I
ran a Thunder weapon of dual blade so I
did pretty well just do it using those
oh yeah guys going to be the end of the
video hope you guys did enjoy it's a
pretty short one but it's it's crucial
adayar he really doesn't have much to
begin with and he's also not that hard
of a boss and I mean obviously yeah the
flash pods did make him just a little
bit more tanky and you know just make
this whole fight a little bit harder but
it's something to crazy especially if
you have a pretty long weapon or a
ranged weapon it's basically a cakewalk
from there hey guys like to be if you do
enjoy subscribe for new I covered the
solo guides of although every monster a
monster hunter world and I like to do
discussion videos on the side when I
feel and on top of that my two most
recent videos would be on screen if you
guys do want to check that out with the
guys have a burger yesterday thank you
for watching the video and peace out
[Music]